why has testosterone been dropping so
aggressively over the last couple of
decades when you're in your 40s your
testosterone is about what your dads
would have been in the 60s there's a
bunch of different chemicals that we
call estrogenic these chemicals are in
our food they're in our water
um they're in our Cosmetics body wash
soap and you were able to more than
double your testosterone level what were
you doing yeah
all right guys bang bang I've got Dr
Huntsman here with me uh I want to talk
to you because the testosterone level in
America and really around the world has
been dropping at an alarming rate uh and
there's a lot of debate as to why it's
happening can it stop dropping can we
actually reverse it and there's a macro
conversation around society's
testosterone level the average
testosterone level dropping but there's
also what you can do on an individual
level and so maybe a great place to
start is just like why has testosterone
been dropping so aggressively over the
last couple of decades yeah so it seems
like what we're finding they've done
studies is we're dropping about a
percent per year on average and so that
what that means is you know when you're
in your 40s your testosterone is about
what your dads would have been in the
60s or what your grandpas would have
been in the 60s or 70s
I think the biggest reason comes down to
mainly two things insulin resistance
which is a growing epidemic it's the
most common condition that people suffer
from in the world and then the
estrogenic chemicals that are that are
in our food and so it boils down to
basically we're getting poisoned every
day by all these chemicals and our
nutrition is just not what it used to be
we're eating way more sugar way more
processed food all the seed oils that we
can get into but it's it's lifestyle
factors that are driving this down so
what is insulin resistance let's start
there you're saying that's one of these
two factors what exactly does that mean
so insulin resistance I I Define it with
two things
they have to be in a state where their
body certain it doesn't have to be every
cell in the body but some some of the
cells of their body are not responding
normally to the hormone insulin and
insulin is what dictates what our body
does with sugar insulin is the hormone
where it'll tell our body hey put sugar
here put sugar there and then the second
point for insulin resistance would be
that they have too much insulin so we
call them hyperinsulinemia just meaning
their body is producing way too much of
it and this is what you know if you've
ever been told you're pre-diabetic or
you hear those types of terms
pre-diabetes is insulin resistance
insulin resistance will be going on for
10 to 15 years even before someone gets
diagnosed as a diabetic and what are the
tests that somebody would take to know
whether they're insulin resistant or not
the there's two two tests and it's
pretty simple it's a simple blood draw
you would take a fasting insulin and
that that number will range anywhere
from it depends on the lab at 3 to 23. I
want to see see people under seven okay
and on a fasting insulin so you'd go in
you haven't eaten breakfast they dry
your blood the other test that you can
do and it's a bit more involved but it's
a better test would be what they call
glucose tolerance test but you take it
with insulin as well so what you do is
you go in they take your blood then you
drink what's basically the equivalent of
a couple Cokes it's 75 grams of glucose
and then every half hour or hour depend
on the lab they'll take your blood again
and they're seeing how is your body
responding to that glucose interesting
and for a healthy person what would
their body's response be and then for an
unhealthy person what would that
response be yeah so for a healthy person
their number you know I would want to
see after a meal you know on a glucose
test it's different but after a meal
typically your insulin will triple so if
you're starting at five and we triple
the 15 great then we're just going to go
back right back down but some people
Iran I ran a ladies blood the other day
and she's starting at 27. so now she
goes and eats something like that she's
going to spike up to like a 75 or even
into a hundred if her insulin is not
working because it because it can't get
the blood out of the sugar the sorry the
sugar out of the blood fast enough
and so we're just looking for those
levels to spike up for a second and then
they come right back down within a
couple hours is ideal and if the higher
your insulin level is uh like as a base
right kind of in normal or fasted time
is it fair to say that it's likely to
spike even higher like there's an
extreme to the spike because you're
already starting at this elevated level
so if a healthy person spikes 3x an
unhealthy base would actually Spike four
or five x yeah it's definitely
definitely possible because the reason
they already have that much insulin is
their body isn't responding to it that's
why we call it insulin resistant right
basically these cells
grow so big insulin makes them grow and
so it makes fat cells grow
and it's
the Cell saying I'm done I can't take
any more and so then that the pancreas
which is where insulin comes from has to
kick out more insulin to get the same
response that it could have if these
cells were responding normally I told
you before we started that like I'm not
a doctor uh I'm super super naive when
it comes to a lot of the stuff but I've
done enough reading online where like
maybe I'm dangerous and so is it fair to
say that like a quote-unquote healthy
skinny person that uh doesn't have these
like inflated uh fat cells is kind of
how I would describe it they can
actually accept more insulin process the
insulin and therefore uh their body is
kind of working as designed whereas
people who have the fat cells who have
actually been uh kind of enlarged that's
where they are resistant to being able
to accept the insulin is that like a
good way to think about it yeah we'd
have to we'd have to be careful with
that anymore because we're finding more
and more that there are so many people
who are skinny they look slender they
look healthy they're still insulin
resistant interesting why is that it it
all boils down to what they're eating I
mean insulin resistance is driven by
what we eat and so these people may be
eating like garbage and just for
whatever genetically you know they won
the lottery where they can eat whatever
they want they don't gain weight but
metabolically they're still unhealthy
they've done us they did a study a few
years back where they looked at I don't
know I can't remember how many people
but they found 12 percent of Americans
are metabolically healthy and those
percent are healthy 12 are metabolically
healthy and the way they were
determining that is this way they
measure called metabolic syndrome and
metabolic syndrome is insulin resistant
so they checked their waist
circumference their
triglycerides HDL blood pressure there's
a few things like that 12 percent of
people were healthy in every category
and that was it and that includes obese
people and you know skinny people yeah
is it um if it's possible for a skinny
person to be metabolically unhealthy is
it possible for a person that is above
kind of the average weight to be
metabolically healthy yeah in general
um it depends on how how much we Define
overweight right but if they're if
someone's got an extra 10 to 15 pounds
20 pounds yeah they could they could be
metabolically healthy now if someone's
got 50 pounds extra weight no they're
they're I don't care how good they feel
metabolically there's something that
needs fixed okay and you said the first
was insulin resistance the second major
contributor is this like estrogenic uh
kind of food uh composition what exactly
does that mean
so there's there's a bunch of different
chemicals that we call estrogenic
estrogenic means when it gets into the
body it's going to act like estrogen so
our cells have these little like
receptors that just can take on
different hormones take on different
substances right and kind of turns them
on
some of these chemicals will get in
there and they turn on our estrogen
receptors now how this plays in the you
know context of testosterone would be
now as a man I have a lot more estrogen
activity than I normally should which
will suppress testosterone right because
the more estrogen in my body the more my
body is told don't produce testosterone
generally essentially yeah the body is
just in a state a higher estrogen so the
brain thinks oh I don't need to produce
testosterone right now
because estrogen is converted from
testosterone everywhere all estrogen was
testosterone first and so if the bodies
if the brain sees oh there's a bunch of
estrogen estrogen around oh I must have
produced enough testosterone I'm good
and I can just skip a skip exactly just
it just starts to shut things down now
this these chemicals are in our food
they're in our water they're in our
Cosmetics body wash soap you name it
these chemicals are just everywhere
right now
and why is that is this the food
companies that are putting it in there
is it uh just like a natural byproduct
of them trying to I don't know
Refrigeration or the way that we filter
water or like like it's not like uh
things that are actually made to enhance
your uh desire for the food like how
much on the spectrum of uh conspiracies
do you think like the actual increase in
estrogen and food is it goes to a little
bit of both of what you said some of it
is like take food coloring for instance
that's purely put in there to make the
food more desirable red red 40 and red
three in particular are the ones that
get pointed to as this estrogen issue
the only reason they're putting red 40
in food is to make it look better make
it look more appealing you'll find it in
a lot of kids food like my wife my wife
bought some Lucky Charms the other day
and I looked at the ingredients I said
that's got red 40 in there we're not
eating that not the not that we ate a
ton cereal anyway but
the other the other side of it is like
Plastics so they use these ingredients
in Plastics that for whatever reason
they either they're cheaper or they make
the plastic a little better like BPA or
phthalates or the two most common
and they just leach into the water they
they absorb through our skin if we're
putting them on our skin things like
that so some of it is just
cost I'm sure a lot of these ingredients
are cheaper and
a lot of these ingredients have been
banned in other countries you look at
the EU and even China you know places
like that they they have banned a lot of
these things in America you know we're
not big on Banning things and I you know
I'm I'm for that generally but some of
these chemicals we just shouldn't be
using yeah
the one example I always use almost
every single one of my friends has some
story where uh they went to a European
country at some point in their life uh
they ate like absolute not you know
nonsense uh they eat the pastries they
ate all the bread they like everything
that you're not supposed to eat right uh
and they came back and somehow they
still weighed the same or less and some
people it's because they don't ever move
and they were walking a lot or something
but there's many people who are like I
measure like I took the same number of
steps in Europe as I did in America how
can I eat so poorly
but really it boils down to from my
understanding it's just like they use
better ingredients and so yes maybe
you're eating more carbohydrates or
breads or whatever uh it's just nowhere
near what's actually putting the food in
America yeah well and a big part too is
the sugar you go eat somewhere outside
of America and you eat the same exact
food it's gonna taste like half a sweet
at times a lot of people come to America
and they're like everything tastes sweet
because we put so much sugar and then if
we get on the estrogenic side the two
biggest ones when we're talking pastries
and Breads and things like that would be
glyphosate which is Roundup
and atrazine which is another herbicide
type you know weed killer atrazine is
banned in almost every other country we
use it by far the most we use 80 million
pounds of it a year in America mostly on
corn
the next closest country I think uses
200 000 pounds and that's Brazil wow
yeah like it's it's unbelievable the EU
is banned atrazine China has banned
atrazine and it is highly estrogenic
meaning it gets in the body and
activates those estrogen receptors and
so if you're eating corn if you're
eating they spray it on soy as well if
you're eating either of those you're
getting atrazine unless you're eating
organic and then glyphosate which is
Roundup that's the one a lot of people
have heard of because of Monsanto and
the lawsuits against them over this
chemical it it's not estrogenic per se
but it damages the testicles in men
they've tested this in rats they can't
really run these tests in humans because
it's not ethical but
so you get these two chemicals the
glyphosates mainly on our wheat but also
in the corn and then atrazine and
basically anytime you eat some grains
you're getting bombarded with these
chemicals what does it do to the
testicles so they've shown in Rat
studies with glyphosate that it damages
what are called the lighting cells or
latex cells those are the cells that
produce testosterone that's just one of
the things that glyphosate does
glyphosate has been tied to cancer it's
been tied to leaky gut which is one that
you hear more and more about where the
you know just gut dysfunction basically
and that's why there's there's multiple
class action lawsuits against Monsanto
right now over Roundup
and that's one where it that's one that
really bothers me that they use it a lot
because a lot of times they are spraying
it on the wheat or corn not necessarily
because of the weeds but they're
crops will ripen faster when they spray
it with Roundup so then they get their
crops quicker higher yield higher yield
exactly yeah and why do you think
America hasn't been this stuff is it
just there's large corporations they're
making more money because the higher
yields they have you know less loss
because of weeds and things like that so
it's like a pure we use this because
people make more money or there are
other reasons
I think it's a mix I think there's
definitely big big food is very powerful
um and big food is really linked to you
know big Pharma not to get too
conspiracy but they're very linked their
lobbying power is very strong
I also think part of it is you know in
America we're not big on Banning things
that's kind of you know we kind of like
to take the government out of things at
least I do I like to keep the government
out of my stuff and so I think that's a
big part of it too is we just don't look
at it but the f I think the biggest
problem is the FDA they move so slowly
at anything atrazine we've known as a
problem for a while
they spent
five years doing a study of how much
atrazine is in our food and our water
it's what's turning the frogs female
when you hear it you know Alex Jones and
those saying it's turning they're
turning the frogs gay well it's it's not
really but frogs are being turned
infertile by atrazy what is happening
there
I don't know I have heard the I've seen
the headlines and I was like okay
whatever right but I don't know the
exact mechanism on how it damages frogs
but I do know that atrazine is being
troubled over and over again to make
frogs infertile make fish infertile and
again we can't really study it in humans
but it's not that big of a leap to say
maybe it's doing damage to us as well
the the amount that it takes to harm
frogs is something about 200 units in
the water
are regulations from the FDA allow 3 000
units in our water
and so we can have 10 times as much they
say is safe in the EU
zero is allowed in the water you know
places like that so I think a big part
is the FDA just dragging their feet and
not doing their job yeah with water
specifically
um what is like the best practices right
so yeah uh don't drink tap water is like
I think generally something that people
now are starting to kind of wake up to
uh I it's important to call out that
there's places in America that you know
uh Jackson Mississippi right I think
Flint Michigan had a huge issue as well
where like literally the water is looks
like it's a third world country right so
like those are the extremes outliers I
think everyone kind of uh understands we
should immediately address those and
like if you live in America and don't
have clean drinking water like that's
[__] right and we should solve those
problems but what you're talking about
is not the extremes you're talking about
like literally pick any city in America
and if I go to the faucet and I take tap
water it has these elevated uh levels of
various chemicals that are in it
is it simple as like I put my water into
like a Brita filter thing that I store
in my refrigerator like what should
people be doing yeah filtering is key I
mean that's bare minimum what someone
should be doing get a Brita filter get
one of those that you put on your TAP
now they're not the best filters out
there that's why they cost you know
they're fairly expensive which is great
too for someone who who needs that
everywhere
you are our water has contaminants in it
right there's no purely very little Pure
Clean Water anymore now if you live in
somewhere that's a hayag
place like Texas or you know some places
in the midwest you're going to have a
lot more of these type of chemicals in
your water but somewhere like here like
you know down here in Florida I know
you've got high levels of estrogen in
your water just straight estrogen great
it's turning you more feminine just from
birth control
women are taking birth control they go
to the bathroom the filtration process
that the cities do does not pull out
what the chemical called ee2 that is
birth control and so what but charcoal a
charcoal filter like a Brita will do
that it will pull it out so that's in my
house
I have an under the counter two-stage
filter
um costs like 200 bucks and that's all
we drink that's all we cook with I'll
wash dishes with the regular tap water
but for drinking water we filter
everything and my kids know that we've
just trained them where there's some in
the fridge they can grab some or they
get it out of the tap like and we live
in an area where we're considered to
have some of the cleanest water in the
country yeah out in Wyoming where I live
I'm still filtering everything because I
just don't want any of that stuff and
how big of an improvement do you think
it actually does to the water right like
I'm assuming you can't get to perfect
but it's a pretty big leap if I'm just
simply filtering yeah the only way
you're gonna get like the purest
cleanest water you could get would be
through distillation you get a distiller
they're fairly expensive they're kind of
a pain in the butt
um but if you want Pure Clean Water it's
going to have everything out of it get
it get a water distilling station how
much does it cost
you know and on the counter one for you
know that'll make about a gallon of time
you're about five six hundred bucks you
can get them cheaper on Amazon or
somewhere like that but they're out of
China and I don't really trust the
components
um if you want like one that's gonna do
you know 12 20 gallons at a time you're
you're into the thousands then yeah um
but they're great like I I used to only
drink distilled water and I did notice a
bit of difference but with a good high
quality filter you're still going to get
out over 99 of stuff I mean and the the
thing with water is you're probably not
going to notice a huge difference when
you start filtering your water as far as
your health goes you're not going to
notice this big oh my gosh I feel so
much better it's more of a let's just
stop doing as much damage as we can it's
a compounding thing exactly right you're
heading in the right direction now
exactly now the water quality that comes
in a water bottle is uh the next thing I
want to talk about so compare that to
the tap water forget the plastic
component of the water bottle right but
just like what's actually the water in
the water bottle how much cleaner is
that normally than a happen you know any
city in America
depends on the company okay some of
these companies
um and I'm not going to call anyone out
by name because I don't know but some of
these companies literally are taking tap
water and putting it in a bottle of
water and selling it you know that's
what they're doing now if you take a
company like I will a company I do like
and what I tend to buy when I'm out and
about is smart water and it is more
expensive smart water is distilled they
they distill their water and then bottle
it and so yeah you'll still get some
Plastics but I know that the water when
it got put in there you know assuming
they're not lying about their process is
clean and so that's that's where I tend
to go out you know spring waters and you
know all these other companies I just
don't know what they're doing
um are they I usually tend to reach for
spring water if I can't get a you know
if I can't get a Smart Water
um I you know ones that just say you
know bottled in Atlanta Georgia or
whatever I tend to avoid those because I
just assume they're putting tap water in
there yeah and then the plastic bottle
what is that doing to the water so if
you put clean water and let's say this
the Smart Water you put that in there
and it's as good as you're gonna get you
know in a kind of pre-packaged uh um
consumption what does the plastic bottle
do to change that water that's so bad so
plastic is going to leach into the water
for sure when when plastic is heated and
there's a liquid inside some of that
plastic is going to get in there so and
I'm even talking like room temperature
it doesn't have to be real hot so when
they're being shipped and all that
and so everyone knows about BPA most
people have heard of BPA and so a lot of
a lot of companies are moving away from
BPA but there's this other chemical
called phthalates which actually starts
with a P it's pth
um phthalates
smart water for one uh if you see if you
look at the bottom you know every
plastic thing has its you know little
recycle symbol and a number
number one is has phthalates that's what
smart water uses so I've kind of even
like on them like gosh I can't even
drink them because now I'm getting
phthalates which are very estrogenic
again going back to that they turn on
your estrogen phthalates they say are
the most common chemical we are exposed
to every day and that is from plastic
and so yeah anytime you're drinking
plastic you know bottled water you're
going to be getting some plastic now you
have to kind of weigh that when I travel
like like I am now I drink bottled water
I just know I'm gonna be getting some
plastic but hopefully you know hopefully
the water in there is going to do less
damage than you know you know if I were
to drink the water out of the sink yeah
uh there's a liquid death right there uh
I so scared to do this but if you grab
that let's see what they have because
um I'm an investor in this business and
it had nothing to do with healthy water
it literally was cool branding they're
gonna go They're Gonna sell this right
um but in it is water and also they
don't have plastic bottles right it's
the uh kind of more like a beer can if
you will
um that one I think may be flavored so
it probably has some stuff they even say
death to plastic on here they're
anti-plastic oh yeah I love it yeah yeah
oh they're definitely against the uh big
plastic is going down right together
we're on board but but I wonder you know
forget the branding for a second forget
any flavors or whatever like if
water companies simply put water into a
can rather than a plastic bottle that
seems like based on what you're saying
like that'd be a pretty big Improvement
for most people I I think so you know I
haven't studied too much the interaction
that it would have with you know this in
this made of aluminum or something like
that but yeah I I think it would um now
cost wise you're probably increasing
your costs quite a bit to do that yeah
the less plastic we can use especially
from our drinks the better A lot of
people will drink their you know coffee
through a plastic lid they're just
pounding plastic the whole time they're
doing that maybe I shouldn't do that now
take that lid off and even a lot use a
straw that's plastic
get yourself a metal straw it'd probably
be better like yeah it really would and
even a lot of those coffee cups are
lined with plastic so you put when you
put a hot liquid in some to plastic
you're making them probably worse uh
iced coffee I guess I'm avoiding a
little bit of plastic maybe
um okay so where else are Plastics like
really kind of infiltrating our life
obviously bottled water is like a
no-brainer it's something that people
they go to the grocery store they go to
the gas station the airport wherever
like they're picking it up they're using
it uh they give it to their kids quite a
bit right sporting events things like
that like it's literally has infiltrated
Society
um are there other big areas where you
try to avoid interacting with plastics
hey guys what's going on I hope that
you're enjoying this conversation but I
wanted to interrupt for a quick second
and tell you about a brand new
conference that I'm hosting on March 4th
at the Miami Beach Convention Center the
event is called lyceum Miami and tickets
are completely free for anyone who wants
to come I'm bringing together many of
the most popular guests from the podcast
cast over the last couple of years some
of the guest speakers that we've already
announced are people like Vivek
ramaswamy from strive asset management
or Delian and Mike Solana from Founders
fund Chris Williamson from the modern
wisdom podcast Cody Sanchez from
contrarian thinking and billionaire
Christian augermeyer among many others
I've got a number of amazing surprise
guests as well some that you definitely
will not expect and others that come
from walks of life that you will be
scratching your head as to how I even
got them to show up but come check out
lyceum Miami on March 4th the lyceum was
a public gym in Athens Greece where
people used to come together talk about
ideas and debate topics that were
important to society I want to meet
people in person in real life once again
after three years of a Hiatus from real
life events and so I'm hosting the event
and as I mentioned anyone from anywhere
can come to this event completely for
free all you need to do is go to
lyceummiami.com and you'll be able to
pick up a free general admission ticket
make sure you claim your ticket in order
to get in through the doors lyceum Miami
is going to be a great time so come
check it out come hang out with me many
of the popular guests from the podcast
and other like-minded individuals lyceum
Miami March 4th Miami Beach Convention
Center I hope to see you there alright
let's get back into this conversation
yeah it's hard because like I said
plastic are so pervasive
um there are some companies that do make
chicken you know and they will inject
these brines or you know something like
that into the chicken before they sell
it a lot of times those brines will have
phthalates in them not just
contamination from the syringe there's
literally that ingredient is in what
they're injecting so even some of our
meat like you just can't avoid it all
together it's impossible like I said
they have found phthalates in polar
bears you know up in the North Pole
these these polar bears have plastic in
them that they got from eating the
salmon that got from the water you know
and so I think doing the bare minimum
would be to avoid drinking hot drinks
out of you know plastic when we can and
just minimize the use of those type of
things you'll do you'll do pretty good
because even like if I go buy a steak at
the grocery store
that's wrapped in plastic there's gonna
be a little bit of contamination there
it but it's not enough that I'm gonna
worry about that steak I'm still because
I think the benefits of being the steak
are gonna far outweigh the little bit of
plastic that I got in there but the
other the other big part would be um
cosmetics
these products that you know lotion
sunscreens that type of stuff soaps even
they will have these chemicals so you
want to look for phthalate free
on labels and if they don't have it on
there
then that's just one of the problems
with Cosmetics but if they don't have
phthalate free on there I'm just
assuming that they're phthalates in
there and what are the other problems
with the cosmetics and I actually saw a
graphic where uh I think it had a woman
and it was like you know women are being
bombarded by all these chemicals and it
was going through uh you know nighttime
skin routine uh makeup uh perfume like
it had kind of like like the average
American woman here's all the different
things and they were trying to basically
compare it to decades ago uh some of
this was still there but some of it
wasn't and so what else are things to be
concerned about from a cosmetic
standpoint that would be the parabens is
what they're called um and and more and
more companies are figuring this out you
will see paraben free on a lot parabens
are used to anthalates both they're used
to kind of help carry fragrances so if
you're using something that has a
fragrance in it and it doesn't say
paraben free or phthalate free you just
assume it's in there because sometimes
they're hard to spot on the label like
can't even remember all the different
scientific names they put on these
things to try to hide them so yeah
parabens again just they're another one
they promote the estrogen which in women
is a huge problem for breast cancer
breast cancer is very much an estrogen
driven cancer and I you know I'm not
going to say that that's why we see
rises in these things but it's not
helping for sure and so yeah if you're
really looking at Cosmetics you want to
avoid
ones that don't say paraben free on them
if they have a fragrance and then
another another one that some people are
going to hate to hear is lavender
hmm what's going on with lavender it has
been shown to promote estrogen just like
these other ones so Lavender in
particular they they've looked at it
with like young boys even like you know
their mom puts the lavender lotion on or
whatever lavender's everywhere right
Everyone likes to smell lavender and
these boys will start to get what we
call gynecomastia you know where they
basically start to grow breasts in these
12 year old boys really and they have
linked that to Lavender yeah and so I
personally as a man I avoid anything
with lavender in it
um and you know even lavender essential
oil I don't think the essential is bad
as some of this but I just I just don't
even risk it I'm just gonna stay away
from it
so when it comes to lotions and uh I
guess shampoos and soaps like all the
stuff do you just try to go for a scent
free or what what do you try to optimize
for
I I'm lucky enough where I live there's
a company that makes soaps makes things
like that so I'm I'm mainly avoiding
lavender and then with them I know
they're making it from goat milk and I
know they're just using a few other
essential oils that I'm not worried
about so I use that that's what I have
switched to using what is the name do
you remember Salt River Salt River soap
Works um they're out in in Star Valley
Wyoming where I live
and so that's one one Avenue you could
take is is going that route
I also don't use a lot of Cosmetics I I
really my wife hates when I say this I
don't wash my hair my hair doesn't need
washed it's not getting dirty now if I
go work out maybe but even then I really
I just rinse it out and clean it out and
I'm good to go
um and so even on you know my body I
don't use a ton of Cosmetics because I
think we use way too much like I said
when people lather stuff on yeah I've
never been someone who does that I
actually uh I've told story before uh I
think I was like 27 28 years old I was
talking to my wife and she was like uh
um where's your face wash stuff and I
was like I've never washed my face
before she's like what do you mean I was
like well the most I had done at that
point in my life was like the bar soap
right right in the shower and like
whatever I got some dirt
um and it blew me away in terms of uh
how much people put on the face now face
wash I'm sure is not nearly as bad as if
you're going and sticking on you know a
pound of makeup every day right right
um but is there things that you can do
uh for example
um I I know that there's been this huge
rise in what I'll call Men's skin care
so obviously uh traditionally and kind
of as a generalization women have really
really been focused on taking care of
their skin men probably not as much kind
of I was like the quintessential example
uh but there has been this rise now of
uh nighttime skin routines or like
lotions to put on your face you know for
the day or whatever is that all kind of
just nonsense or are there maybe like
healthy versions of it what do you think
well you can say it's nonsense if you
think it's nonsense I don't well it
depends on what you what your goal is
right if your goal is to make your skin
look more like a woman then then okay
you know and I say that because not not
in a bad way right if someone wants
their skin to look like yeah great you
do you
but these chemicals that are going to be
in there are literally turning men more
feminine in that's not me saying that
that's scientific journal saying that so
I yeah I'd think the less we're putting
on the better because skin will readily
readily absorb these chemicals and so I
yeah I I'm like you I've never washed my
face granted I didn't suffer with acting
like my wife did her whole life but I
think if she had used less of those
things I think her acne would have been
better than it was when I was in seventh
grade I had really bad acne like there
was like a six month period it was
horrible right and it's like uh there's
like a confidence component to it that
you're just like oh get the [__] off my
face right whatever it's brutal and I
remember uh that I went uh with my
mother and uh there's these like pads
that you could get you could do it and
actually would like burn a little bit
yeah right because you're putting this
stuff on there or whatever and I
remember thinking to myself like
thankfully after you know six months or
whatever I was able to not have to do it
anymore but there's people who have been
doing that for years right even into you
know kind of their 20s or 30s uh they
used that and I can't imagine that those
chemicals are good for you no right no
definitely not good for you now might
they help the acne and that has some
benefit for sure when when I work with
some of these kids that have acne it's
terrible like it destroys their
confidence destroys their ability to
talk to people but yeah to do that for
decades yeah I can't imagine that's
doing anything good in the body yeah
um what about like colognes and perfumes
do you wear any are there concerns
around them yeah there are I I haven't I
haven't worn a clone since I got married
because I didn't feel like I needed to
anymore right so I haven't worn clothes
maybe my wife would say otherwise but
you know I haven't wore clonings
probably 10 years but again it's got a
fragrance in it it's being carried by a
by a phthalate most likely and so yeah
again you're spraying now if you're just
spraying it on your clothes
um you're probably not getting too much
so if you're someone that wants to wear
some clone or something or some perfume
I would say spray it on your clothes
Don't Spray It On Your Skin would be my
recommendation yeah I mean and maybe
that's kind of like the the middle
ground right because people like I
almost smell like [__] but yeah right I
also don't want to be basically killing
myself right
um and then in terms of uh not washing
your hair that much use I'll call it a
special soap but just kind of a
healthier soap yeah is there anything
else that you do uh from like a a
personal care or Cosmetics anything like
that that's noteworthy no I mean for me
thankfully I've been blessed with pretty
good skin and that kind of stuff I got
some Latin America Heritage and so I
personally haven't had to do much other
than that and my skins you know my skin
everything stays pretty healthy yeah the
um the the reason why I originally found
you uh on the internet was uh you had
this thread and you were talking about
how at the age of 24 uh you had
a very low testosterone level and you're
able to increase your testosterone as
you got older yep help me understand
like what is the average testosterone
level of somebody in America or like
what should it be and then like what's a
low range and a high range just so we
can start to understand like how you
move these numbers yeah so we'll we'll
talk about in terms of total
testosterone since that's what most
people know it's not the best measure I
prefer a free testosterone measure we
can get into that too but for total
testosterone set at 24 25 years old I
was about 250 nanograms per deciliter
that's really low that would be
considered hypogonadism what is that
meaning your testicles are not working
like they're supposed to I literally
you're not producing as nearly as much
testosterone as you should the upper
range the upper range the labs will put
on testosterone be 900 to a thousand
okay which when we're in our teenagers
boys
um we're gonna be we're going to have
levels around thousand twelve hundred
even fifteen hundred for a really high T
kid wow now I don't think
physiologically there really should be
an upper limit I don't think if
someone's at a thousand and the range
says 900 I don't think a thousand's bad
at all the average in America right now
is going to be between 350 to 450 in in
most middle-aged men that number should
be double that we should be in the 6 700
range okay and natural we'll just talk
about natural testosterone for the
moment so no trt none of that stuff but
natural testosterone levels can you have
too much whether you're a kid or in
middle age I don't think so
um some people you know try to tie
testosterone to aggressiveness and
criminality and
it's never been really shown to be true
and so I really the things that
testosterone does let's go through that
it increases your sex drive it increases
your muscle mass increases your bone
mass helps you look leaner and you know
makes your appearance better gives you
better energy better focus like how can
we have too much of that like everyone
benefits from that men and women
everyone can benefit from a little more
of all those things yeah so you went
from 24 or 25 to kind of mid 30s and you
were able to uh more than double your
testosterone level and maybe we can kind
of go through like what were you doing
over that period of time to really kind
of keep moving the testosterone level up
yeah so last I checked my levels I'm
somewhere in the 630 to 650 range
somewhere there and Rule says as I'm
getting older it should be going down so
mine has gone up
I think the biggest key for me was I was
in chiropractic school
um and I was having a lot of focus
issues couldn't couldn't really function
I couldn't figure out why I went to a
friend of mine and he he's a big uh
gluten guy he he's Celiac he thinks a
lot of people have gluten issues so he
convinced me to go off gluten for six
months now I'm not saying the gluten was
a problem
I was insulin resistant and I didn't
know I I had stopped working out nearly
as much as I had you know in in my
undergrad partly because of a back
injury I blew out my back herniated two
discs ended up walking the cane for a
year and so I just was not active was
still eating the same junk that I'd been
eating you know pizza for pizza for
dinner every night you know we would go
to Little Caesars and eat the entire
Five Dollar Pizza by ourselves you know
and so inadvertently what I what I've
realized is as I took gluten out of my
diet
it reduced my carb intake massively
because I wasn't really replacing it and
so my carb intake probably went from 300
grams a day to 75 or 80 grams a day not
quite to the ketogenic level but getting
in those range and so by fix working on
that insulin resistance just by accident
everything got better everything my life
improved my my focus got better my
energy was better my sex drive increased
and I was newly married at this time we
were trying we were trying to have kids
that's why I started down this down this
route of looking at my testosterone and
so for me that was the biggest key now
I've added things since then where I
work out more I lift more weights I've
never never been a big weightless guy I
don't love it but I do it now I shrink
train now at least I'm gonna do
100 push-ups a day at least build some
just work on that muscle
um and then just cleaning up the diet in
general I eat way less sugar than I used
to
um this this estrogenic chemical world
that that's more new to me I've really
started going down that in the last six
months or so of getting those things out
of my diet and I expect that's gonna I'm
gonna see more Improvement by doing that
and then alcohol as well I think you cut
out alcohol well or did you bring it
back or well no so I actually so so I
put that in the thread about that thread
was you know I'm giving advice on what
people can do I don't drink I never have
um in My Religion we don't use alcohol
and so that wasn't something I cut out
but if someone wants to help their
testosterone they need to cut out
alcohol at least significantly reduce it
you know a lot of people are having a
beer every day you know and when we were
taught we were taught if you know man
for have one to two drinks a day would
technically in the medical world be
considered alcoholic and so what alcohol
is going to do is really going to
deplete your B vitamins if you're
drinking too much if it B vitamins are
very needed for health the testosterone
levels they help suppress certain things
keep them down so that our body can make
more testosterone so yeah cutting out
alcohol is a great idea if you want to
boost your tea and then what about the
relationship to weight right because I
saw that you said like if you lose
weight your testosterone levels
naturally go up and this goes back to
some of the insulin conversation we
started with yeah it goes back to
insulin a bit but also just the fat
cells themselves can be a problem for
testosterone so in man and women too
um
where that testosterone to estrogen
occurs part of that is in the fat cells
themself this is called aromatization so
literally the fat cells which have
receptors for testosterone testosterone
gets to the fat cell and the fat cell
says I'm going to turn you to estrogen
and then testosterone levels start to
decline because literally it's just
being converted and so reducing your
body weight even 20 pounds can make a
significant difference on your
testosterone level because you won't get
that conversion happening nearly as much
really 20 pounds could be a huge huge
difference yeah because most people were
talking most people are in the 30 to 40
50 pound range and so you know of
overweight you know I'm you know
sometimes morbidly obese is a different
conversation but yeah you draw if you're
40 pounds overweight and you lose 20
pounds you're going to make a big
difference for for your energy for your
insulin resistance but also to your
testosterone levels yeah I had a friend
who told me uh six foot 200 pounds is
kind of anyone who can be six foot and
under 200 pounds uh and obviously people
are optimize it for different things or
whatever but like the average person uh
that was like a line he's like once you
start getting up into 210 to 15 220 uh
for a male he's like literally your
height is not increasing right right
it's just you're going wider and uh
there's this like big difference in the
physiological components and
measurements of your body being under
200 versus over I thought it was
fascinating where he was just like yeah
every height kind of has a weight yeah
that
muscle mass all this stuff kind of
changes the number a little bit but
definitely being under a certain weight
will completely change the way you feel
uh and kind of things you do on a
day-to-day basis yeah absolutely
absolutely I mean the biggest so for me
I'm five six five seven I'm pretty short
guy biggest I've ever been is about 210
and I felt terrible when I was that that
big and even if I let let myself get up
to the 190 192 range
compared to where I felt 175 even
it's night day difference I have much
better energy
just every part of my life feels better
and that's a 15 pound difference now I
ideally at my height I'm probably more
closer to the 160 155 range depending on
muscle mass but even that difference
between 175 and 190 makes a huge
difference for me yeah you also
mentioned sleep uh I two years ago uh
was not sleeping at all like I was
horrible uh and two years ago I was like
I want to get better at this and it's
probably the single most important thing
that I changed in my life uh over the
last two years and it's just like sleep
eight hours there's all kinds of fancy
stuff that you can try and do and I've
probably tried a bunch of them right but
like literally just sleeping eight hours
I feel like a different person than if I
sleep six and a half yeah and what's
going on in my body when I'm actually
sleeping eight versus six or seven
yeah so when we don't sleep enough our
cortisol level will rise cortisol is
it's kind of known as the stress hormone
right
cortisol
increases your insulin resistance so if
you one bad night of sleep just one so
say you got a young kid I got young kids
sometimes you don't get the best sleep
and you feel like crap the next day that
one night of bad sleep will make you
more insulin resistant that next day wow
just one night and so imagine someone
who's been doing that for decades right
it's it's that increase in cortisol
cortisol decreases testosterone to tie
it back to the testosterone and again
also increases
insulin resistance and so yeah the key
is sleep eight hours like I I these I
have so many patients tell me we're like
yeah I sleep three hours every night I
feel great and like dude you're not the
exception to the rule there are some
exceptions there are some people
um Matthew Walker has done a lot of
studies on these
um he wrote the book why we sleep and
yeah there are this is very very small
percentage where they do function well
at four hours sleep
99.99 of us we need eight hours of sleep
every night and that's like you said
that's the easiest thing people can do
to make themselves feel better yeah I
think it's Ryan holiday uh in one of his
books he talks about like most people
aren't disciplined to sleep eight hours
they don't have the discipline to do it
and his point was uh for most people
your job your life your kids your family
you know something in your kind of
day-to-day requires you to wake up at a
certain time and some people that's you
know 5 a.m some people that's 8 A.M
whatever the time is you you gotta kind
of a hard start uh
and so the discipline is actually not
when you wake up it's when you go to
sleep and we are programmed as a society
to stay up later TV and you know phones
and uh dinners and like all these type
of things but his point was like if you
have the discipline to go to sleep at
eight or nine o'clock which just saying
someone's gonna go Super 8 o'clock
they're like whoa you're a weirdo yeah
right why would you go to sleep at eight
o'clock that's when my kids go to bed
you know yeah right like you're not a
kid you're an adult but like having the
discipline to go to sleep at an earlier
time actually will increase the odds you
get eight or more hours of sleep and
then that allows you to wake up next day
you have more energy like like it is
this kind of uh uh circular thing
um but it's hard it's really hard for
the average adult in America to go to
sleep at even nine o'clock well and
these these problems kind of compound on
themselves too because if you're not
sleeping well
if you're not sleeping enough say you're
going to bed at midnight you gotta get
up at five then you're having all those
issues from the sleep but also when we
get more insulin resistant when we get
more of these type of things well one of
the symptoms or one of the things that
insulin resistance can cause is sleep
issues so now you're compounding the
issue by not sleeping and then you're
getting more unhealthy so then you can't
sleep so yeah I I tell people schedule
when you go to bed don't don't schedule
when you wake up and we you know you
need to know when you need to wake up I
got to get up at 6 30 every day so I
need to know I got to be in bed by 9 30
or 10 because for me I'm one it takes me
a little bit to fall asleep takes me a
little bit to wind down I need to give
myself a window of probably nine hours
counting that you know half hour is
going to take me to fall asleep and so
you really need a plan and I you know I
get caught in too my kids go to bed at
eight I'm like okay now I can you know
do some stuff now I'm free 12 31 am
rolls around I'm like oh gosh I gotta
get up at seven and now I know the next
day I'm not gonna gonna be at my best
you know I try to do those on you know
when I have a day off and so it's not as
big a deal but I shouldn't do it
physiologically I'd be better I need
eight hours every night regardless the
two things I notice uh related to sleep
outside of like mood and all that type
of stuff is uh one if I don't sleep a
lot I
eat like an absolute animal the next day
yeah and so there's got to be some
relationship maybe you kind of
understand the science
um and then the second thing is uh I
always say that there's like uh people
who step on scales and then people who
like when you wake up in the morning and
you go to brush your teeth and just like
look it in the mirror you pretty much
know I'm getting bigger I'm getting
smaller right like whether you want to
admit it to yourself or not like you
know and one of the things I uh I've
noticed over the years is like if I
sleep eight or more and especially if
it's eight and a half or nine hours uh
you feel and psychologically have
convinced yourself that you're actually
Slimmer like your body almost feels like
it is uh processing food or what I don't
know exactly what it is but like
it feels like this is more in tune with
like the way my body wants to be than if
you sleep six hours and you kind of wake
up and you feel like [__] and then you
eat horribly like it kind of compounds
on itself yeah and that's not just a
mental thing there is a physiologic
answer to that interesting to both of
them so those Cravings you talked about
right man I mean you like garbage the
next day that's cortisol cortisol
increases our cravings for sugar and
that type of stuff so when you get a bad
night's sleep your cortisol is going to
be elevated the next day and it's it's
again it's a compounding problem because
now you're more insulin resistant
because you had a bad night's sleep now
you're gonna eat a bunch of sugar you're
blood sugar's gonna go up you're going
to get more insulin resistant that day
now I'm not saying one by nine sleep is
gonna make some insulin resistant
forever but the other part on the the
Slimmer part sleep plays a huge role if
someone wants to lose weight they need
to be sleeping eight hours every night
why is that again cortisol cortisol
another effect of it will make you
retain water
and so some of that is is the body shed
in water but yeah you want to shed that
water your body shouldn't hold on to it
and and so cortisol plays a big role in
managing our weight as well that
interplay between it and insulin is huge
do you have any sort of like nighttime
routine to increase the odds that you're
going to sleep well I got four kids
there ain't no routine
um no for me
I really don't
um now I've kind of I've I've ruined
myself in some ways I can't fall asleep
if I'm not listening to something so for
me that's what I found in college was
I've always struggled with sleep issues
kind of since I was a kid I I think I
ruined myself as a kid reading I
actually I was the type of kid that got
grounded from Reading because I was
reading too late you know you're like my
brother I got a brother who literally
he's actually a doctor so it's funny but
uh uh there was a story where once my
parents were worried like we were all
sneaking out of the house doing all this
stuff and they would go my brother's
room he'd be under the covers of the
flashlight Harry Potter the Harry Potter
yes absolutely see me and your brother
should talk but uh the what I have done
lately
um is I did get a pair of blue blockers
interest classes I noticed a massive
difference when I use them because a lot
of times when I get home once my kids
are in bed I I still am reading a lot I
study a lot and most of that I'm doing
on my phone
and so I just you know I know about blue
light I know the damage it can do to
your circadian rhythm and your melatonin
uh hormone and so I went to a buddy mine
who's an optometrist and had to make me
a pair of blue blocking glasses and they
just look like regular glasses they're
not like the yellow tinted one and
yellow tinted ones are fine but I do
notice a real big difference in how long
it takes me to fall asleep if I put
those suckers on as soon as I get home
really so when you get home six seven
o'clock whatever uh you're putting the
glasses on and pretty much trying to
wear them till you go to sleep yeah
pretty much and um will you also wear
the Muna if you're not staring at a
screen
no I I will take them off if I'm not you
know watching TV or on my phone or
something I then I just come off because
I I don't need glasses they're not
prescriptive so yeah but if I'm I have a
screen at night and I've been I kind of
neglected for a while but I've tried to
do it better lately
um just anytime I'm at the computer on
my phone whatever I have I'm trying to
have those classes yeah
the only two things I've ever done that
seem to have an impact and again I I'm
always worried that like maybe it's
Placebo stuff versus like actually
working
um is uh I now try to read before I go
to bed I used to be on my computer all
the time but like read a physical book
um and that seems to help and I'm sure
it has a lot to do with the screens and
things like that uh but the second thing
I'm scared to admit this but uh every
night I drink uh chamomile tea but I get
it with uh has a little bit of melatonin
in the tea bag
um and I don't like you know I've
traveled and stuff I don't have it and I
don't feel like I'm like missing it or
have like a really bad night of sleep or
anything
um and so I don't know how much of it's
just like it's part of the routine
before I go to bed as I drink some tea
and then go to bed versus like it's
actually doing something how much should
people worry if they're drinking whether
it's chamomile tea or something else and
especially if it has melatonin in it
before they go to bed every night yeah
chamomile by itself I will you know
great yeah there's a lot for centuries
you know Millennia people have used
chamomile tea to help them sleep like I
don't think there's anything wrong there
when you bring melatonin into the
picture now I was taught in my nutrition
you know program
that if you take melatonin you're going
to suppress your body's natural ability
to
produce it right The more I've studied
that I cannot find how that mechanism
actually works I I have never been able
to sufficiently prove that to myself
that that is true so depending on the
dose you know I I I'm not I kind of live
by the mindset of we shouldn't have to
rely on any outside chemical to feel
good right but if you're taking a
milligram or two of melatonin and I and
it gets you to sleep whereas you
wouldn't sleep if you didn't take it
great take it I want you to sleep that's
more important and because melatonin is
cheap it's easy to get it's really not
going to have any side effects so I I
personally wouldn't worry too much about
it I told a patient the other day this
17 year old girl that I'm working with
she doesn't sleep she doesn't lay in bed
till five in the morning and her parents
are like we've tried melatonin I said
how much have you tried they said oh you
know five milligrams I said give her 15.
yeah like for short term I'm not going
to do that long term but
and I'm not telling people do that but
for her I need her to sleep so we can
fix her other issues and if she's
getting two or three hours of sleep a
night it's not gonna happen so I said
put her on 15. and well we'll see what
happens yeah the um uh maybe I should
just try the chemical tea without the
melatonin and kind of go from there
um
while you're sleeping do you do anything
like is uh uh environment yeah okay
anything like that like what what do you
kind of do to optimize for the actual
hours that you are sleeping yeah so the
I have three pieces advice two are
pretty common and one's kind of off the
wall
keep your dark your room dark easy I
mean I I live in a smaller Apartments
like my computer's in my room and our
modem can be in there and so I literally
take electrical tape and I cover up
every light that I can even those little
bit of you know little green light to
shine on a power brick I cover them all
up as best I can so keep it dark keep it
cool you want your bedroom cooler at
night you know I ours we put it at 67 68
somewhere in there the other piece so I
so I married so so for people that sleep
with someone else in their bed get
separate blankets do not share a blanket
that is my best advice and we've done
that our whole marriage but that way
you're not being woken up by your spouse
or your you know your girlfriend
boyfriend whoever turning and rolling
like get separate blankets it will make
a difference and then high quality
mattress high quality pillow are huge
yeah
um a pillow can make just buying a
better pillow can make a significant
Improvement in your sleep yeah the um I
haven't gone really really deep down the
pillow thing in two years ago when I
started getting serious about the sleep
thing
um I was introduced to uh Mateo who's
the CEO of eight sleeps got the cooled
mattress oh yeah and um I literally knew
nothing right and he was like dark cool
like the whole thing and he's like
that's why we built this mattress so I
started sleeping on it that is the only
thing that I've done where when I travel
yeah I can tell a huge difference yeah
and the only way to do all your travel
is like you just crank the AC you know
and try to make as cool as you can but
what I noticed is not so much uh the
amount of time that I sleep but it was
actually the deep sleep right I sleep
with a watch on so I get some of the uh
uh the measurements I don't know how
exactly accurate they are but but um it
seems like I get deeper and deeper sleep
the colder that it is and so it's funny
because like even if you don't have a
mattress and kind of all the special
stuff like you literally can just turn
the AC on yeah right and that could be a
huge difference in the amount of sleep
that you get yeah where I live just open
the window you know how cold is it one
degree at my house right now so open up
your windows cold as you want but yeah
temperature temperature and light light
exposure are easy things that anyone can
do doesn't cost you anything like I said
um you know if you don't have AC then
maybe there's an issue there but it'll
make significant Improvement in your
sleep just by making those changes
um and then there's the other things
like we talked about you know chamomile
melatonin magnesium can help a lot I I
do if I know it's going to be a rough
night
you know for whatever reason my mind is
wired up or something I'll I'll take
some CBD and then I'll hit that with
some magnesium as well and that seems to
at least help me calm down on those days
I don't do it every day but what is the
magnesium and what does the CBD do uh
specifically for sleep so magnesium
magnesium is one that most people are
deficient in should take every day now
magnesium is not going to help you fall
asleep any quicker for most people and I
take a blended form there's so many
different kinds of magnesium but
it's going to make your Sleep Quality
better
um you it works on what we call the rest
and digest system your parasympathetic
nervous system which is where a lot of
that repair happens while we're sleeping
our brain is repairing everything's
repairing magnesium is involved in a lot
of those processes and so by giving your
body what it needs your rest is going to
be better now the CBD you know how the
mechanism exactly works I'm not entirely
sure but CBD is just known for its
calming effects
um and so I I'll usually you know I'll
take a 25 milligrams of that or
something just it seems to
when I do take melatonin which is rare
but I do take it
um if I take the CBD with it for me it
seems to Mellow the effects of the
Melatonin as far as the hangover the
next day that you can get some people
get that real bad groggy feeling from
melatonin the next day
um CBD for me completely takes that away
yeah I am when I was in the military uh
this is like one of my deepest darkest
Secrets probably
um we didn't have access to a lot of
different stuff right
um and uh someone else deployed a lot of
guys got addicted to NyQuil because it
had that same kind of thing it helped me
go to sleep and we were sleeping at
weird hours because sometimes we'd go
out at night since we go out during the
day and so you're kind of like off
um and I remember coming back and like
it was pretty hard to get back to
sleeping normal when you're not used to
like you take something that knocks you
out yeah and uh what made me think of it
is melatonin I've never had kind of The
Hangover but you take enough NyQuil yeah
you wake up the next day you're like ah
it's gonna be a tough morning right you
cause you literally do feel that
grogginess well in all NyQuil the the
active ingredient that's putting you to
sleep is the same that's in Benadryl the
the you know the antihistamine and so
it's a diphenhydramine or something like
that but yeah so and that's the same
with like you take a Tylenol PM or any
of those it's got Benadryl in it now
Benadryl is one if people are relying on
that to sleep they need to fix it
because it is messing with your brain
long-term use of that kind of stuff has
been tied to Alzheimer's and dementias
and things like that so yeah if you're
relying on on NyQuil or something like
that talk to someone that can help you
fix your sleep I used it for like a year
probably yeah yeah and it was the thing
where once you got back kind of to like
a normal schedule and all that
um it wasn't easy to get off but it
definitely was like Hey you probably
don't need Nightcore
um another thing that you've mentioned
is zinc what is that in terms of raising
uh testosterone
so zinc zinc is needed to produce
testosterone you can't produce
testosterone without it and a lot of
people just again are we're so nutrient
deficient everywhere and and men in
particular need more zinc than women so
just taking some zinc can you know you
don't have to take a lot 50 milligrams
to 100 milligrams maybe it has been
shown if you're severely deficient it
can improve testosterone now some people
will take zinc and they're like I didn't
notice anything
um which it just tells me okay zinc
deficiency wasn't one of your issues the
other thing that zinc can do will
suppress a different hormone called
prolactin and prolactin based on the
name it's actually what makes women
lactate when they're you know
breastfeeding
but men have it as well prolactin
suppresses the production of
testosterone so if we don't have enough
zinc and B vitamins and some of these
other things to keep the prolactin
levels down then we can have a decrease
in testosterone from that you've
mentioned you know zinc magnesium a
couple of these things like would just a
normal daily vitamin kind of like a
everyday vitamin replace enough of it or
do you think it should be more targeted
than that yeah I mean it depends on the
company I work with some some companies
that you know they're professional lines
that are sold by physicians that there
there's are pretty good but most things
if we're targeting something like
magnesium take separately because most
if you're buying it off the you know off
the shelf of Walmart or something the
magnesium in there is going to be a
crappy form because it's cheap so it'll
be magnesium oxide most likely which is
the cheapest form which is basically
rusted magnesium it's not really going
to help you that much and so for most
things I I don't I don't personally take
a multivitamin I think most people don't
I don't think it's a bad thing to do
um I don't think you necessarily need to
but if yeah if you're targeting
magnesium zinc vitamin D things like
that just just take them on their own
separately and then vitamin D is another
thing that you've mentioned before in
terms of helping to raise testosterone
yeah
um vitamin D again is it it's vitamin D
is an interesting vitamin right we call
it a vitamin it's really acts more like
a hormone in the body interesting it's
even you know it's it's got that if you
look at the actual name it ends in that
oil ol letters which means it comes from
a
comes from a cholesterol synthesized
that way
and most people I think the numbers on
vitamin D is something like 75 80
percent are deficient and it's involved
in so many processes in the body now how
it how it
helps with testosterone
is again it's it's kind of a building
block for some of the things we need to
make testosterone so having our vitamin
D's optimal vitamin D levels optimal is
just going to make that production
happen quicker now for someone like me
you know I got some vitamin D on my walk
over here this morning because it's
sunny here where I live it might be
sunny but we ain't going for a walk
outside in in the winter you know and so
that's it where I live I I take about 5
000 units a day of vitamin D in the
winter um in the summer I don't take as
much because I'm out fishing or I'm out
doing doing what I do in the summer and
so I'm really try I try to build up my
stores in in the summer quite a quite a
lot and spend it and it doesn't take
long 15-20 minutes a day out in the sun
with your skin exposed not putting on
sunscreens which sunscreens are a whole
different volume a whole different route
we could go down but you'll produce
enough vitamin D that you're good for a
while and if you do that all summer even
where I live you're going to have pretty
good amounts stored up vitamin D gets
stored in the body it's it's stored in
fat cells and and so you'll be pretty
good but you know living in Miami if you
spend enough time outside you probably
don't need to supplement much with
vitamin D it'd probably be good yeah
yeah and is that what people who live in
Sunny areas like literally you can just
go outside if you're outside for 30
minutes to an hour you should be good on
vitamin D yeah yeah as long as you're
not like say as long as you're not
covering yourself up with sunscreen
while you do it sunscreen is going to
block the UV rays our skin converts
the two things two Vitamin D from the
activation of the Sun and so if you're
blocking that sun then you're not going
to be producing the vitamin D one of the
things uh when I moved from New York to
Miami that I noticed is uh and it sounds
stupid but like I became happier and uh
so it was like the seasonal depression
stuff like I never really believed in
that and then like I just went back to
New York and I was like oh [__] man
different different area right
um but also I think a lot of it was just
like pure sunlight right and again I
don't know what the science exactly is
but like you feel if you can go outside
and there's Sun for whatever reason
maybe it's just me personally like
people are different but you definitely
feel happier and I'm wondering if there
is science behind that a big part is
vitamin D um I lived in the Northwest
for a while I wouldn't go out in
Portland so we were out Northwest for
four or five years and seasonal
affective disorder is huge out there now
in Portland it starts raining and you
know end of October early November and
it doesn't stop and you don't see the
sun until like may you know like it can
be brutal you can literally go weeks
without seeing the Sun at least where I
live right now it's cold but we we get
sunlight and so that those depressive
disorders are huge up in the Northwest
and a big part the biggest evidence
points towards vitamin D levels
um and yeah taking it in a pill form is
or liquid form is not
you know not ideal but if you later it's
better than knocking any at all so
that's that's why I supplement it myself
what about stress reducing stress uh can
drastically increase testosterone levels
as well that goes to the cortisol
conversation yeah so when you're when
you are stressed out when you're not
sleeping well all those things that re
increase our cortisol
cortisol actively suppresses
testosterone and so if your cortisol is
higher testosterone is going to go down
and again of cortisol's high insulin
resistance is going up so it's that
cortisol testosterone balance that
you're trying to find and so yeah
reducing your stress is huge and that's
easier said than done for some people
you know if your job is the biggest
stressor in your life not everyone can
just quit their job I've had
conversation like that with patients but
again the best way you're going to
reduce your stress is sleeping yeah the
uh maybe like the extreme example of
like a Warren Buffett who sits and I
think he says to read 500 pages a day
right like a pretty stress-free life if
that's the difference
versus you know you can imagine like the
most stressful job in the world how much
of it is uh a Warren Buffett where you
know he's doing it every single day and
it's like pretty low stress versus the
compounding effects of like high stress
every day like is there a balance where
maybe you don't want like zero stress uh
and it's actually healthy to have some
stress sometimes but yeah on the balance
you want to have like a lower stress
life like how do you think about that
hey guys I hope that you're enjoying
this conversation as you probably
realize we don't run any ads on this
show that's right all the other podcasts
all the other YouTube shows that you
watch they have advertisers we don't
have any direct relationships with
advertisers and we simply create this
because we enjoy doing it now that we do
that though we have a team and if you'd
like to support us one way you can do
that is to go subscribe to the pop
letter it's a daily letter that I write
to about 235 000 people about my
personal opinion on financial markets
business technology and Bitcoin just go
to pompletter.com and you can sign up
there I'd love to have you join us and
it's a great easy way to support the
work that the team and I are doing on a
daily basis all right let's get back
into this conversation well if you're
offering me Warren Buffett's life I
think I think I'll take it most days but
yeah I think the lower stress the better
but some people thrive on stress too
right there you get these high
just active individuals like they need
that to to mentally they need it now
maybe physiologically it's doing some
things but yeah I think finding that
balance of where you're pushing yourself
and and increasing that stress but we
need to increase our stress tolerance
right so the stress tolerance would just
mean that you can handle more of it and
not crash because of it um and that goes
to just finding these balances the other
thing in talking to the testosterone
conversation is that
the more testosterone you have the
better you can do in those situations
because it's literally having some
effects on the brain on the amygdala the
amygdalas where like our fear Center is
and and things like that it makes you
want to push and want to drive if you
have more testosterone so then you are
going to work better in those high
stress situations
there's something else that you talked
about and I'm going to butcher how I
pronounce this but uh it's Ash Wong and
huh ashwagandha ashwagon there you go
um and what you said about this was
actually pretty surprising an increased
testosterone by 20 it could increase
sperm count like 170 percent like these
are like big numbers what is that so
ashwagandha is an herb um it's been used
in I think it comes out of India
um somewhere somewhere back you know
that that area it's been used for you
know
Millennia by people over there for all
kinds of ailments but what they found is
it
the way that it helps testosterone and
sperm count in particular is it has a
protective effect for the testicles
actually testicles are where these are
made
and it does that through an antioxidant
effect so it's reducing the amount of
oxidative what we call oxidative stress
um in in the testicles and everywhere in
the body but ashwagandha is probably the
most studied
herbal type thing on testosterone
they've done many many studies and
generally the studies are favorable
um that particular study I decided again
showed 20 Improvement in those men and
they were testing
lower testosterone men right and so
someone you know is like you know
someone that's got optimal levels
already or in five six hundred range
they're probably not going to notice a
20 increase but they they'll they'll
have some some increase from ashwagandha
for sure and what form do most people
take that is that okay you can take
ashwagandha tea I think I don't know how
if it tastes like hay or what but yeah
yeah you know but um yeah most time it's
gonna be capsules and things like this
and maybe even some of the other
vitamins
um when people hear that it increases
your testosterone level they think well
if I take it does it almost have like a
caffeinated effect where it'll make me
hard it'd be harder to go to sleep and
therefore I shouldn't take it at night
and I should take these in the morning
or does it not really it shouldn't
because it's not having an immediate
effect like someone's gonna take
ashwagandha even for a few weeks
probably before they're going to notice
a difference or you know Tanga Ali is
another one you hear a lot about and it
can boost testosterone quite a bit but
it it shouldn't have that type of effect
okay what about caffeine's impact on
testosterone is it a something that
helps or something that hurts it that's
actually I'm not sure on that that's not
one that I've studied
um I've again I go to if you're having
to rely on caffeine every day to
function you got something metabolically
we need to work on you shouldn't have to
rely on it but yeah as far as
testosterone goes I'm not sure yeah it's
interesting because I saw a um I've
signed a couple studies and again uh my
uneducated brain reads this stuff right
I'm like I think I think I get the main
points but uh one of the things that
they're now claiming is that actually
drinking a certain amount of caffeine
usually through coffee uh two you know
two cups or so can help in Long your
life and so it's from like a longevity
standpoint which okay if you're
optimizing for that that's great but I
also do Wonder then you know when you
introduce it especially if you drink a
lot of coffee right what are you doing
to the physiological components of your
body which then potentially changes your
cortisol levels or these other things
that then can like have to knock on
effects and so I I've always joked that
like the human body is kind of like the
economy super complex we all think we
understand it but nobody actually gets
it right right and so that's one that
um I don't think I would change my
caffeine intake necessarily right uh but
it would be interesting to understand
how it has an impact on testosterone
yeah and I I've seen those same type of
studies that show longevity and we
talked before the show like I don't
drink coffee personally I never have but
when we talk a sleep issue some of these
people that come into me saying they're
having sleep issues and I say well when
was your last cup of coffee I had one of
four four in the afternoon there you go
that that's why you can't sleep so I
just help you be be careful don't don't
drink your caffeine 12 hours before you
got a you know 12 10 to 12 hours before
you got to go to bed be done with your
coffee or your tea or whatever you're
getting your caffeine from
it is one of the things that uh I
haven't measured but like you just
intuitively learn your body uh I drink
you know I wake up 6 30ish seven o'clock
um I usually don't actually drink coffee
until 8 30 or 9 and then I used to drink
a coffee at like one o'clock yeah and uh
I noticed that if I don't drink that or
I just move it to like maybe 10 30 11.
huge difference I I started to realize I
was sleeping better and again you know
small brain you're just like okay I
guess like that it must be that and so
you just kind of like slowly learn your
body right you start to change your
habits so that you can at least give
yourself a higher probability like that
I think that's like the average person
is like look I'm not a professional
athlete I'm not you know getting paid uh
For Better or Worse sleep or whatever
but like if I can increase probabilities
I'll do that because it's just going to
help me you know over the long run yeah
well and I would say everyone that you
you are getting paid to have better
sleep right I mean think what think of
everything you got going on in your
business and all that like my business
suffers when I don't sleep well enough
you know and a lot of people will have
that 1pm 2 p.m cup of coffee because
their their Energy's crashing that tells
me you probably got a blood sugar issue
let's let's fix your blood sugar issue
make sure you don't have that afternoon
crash then you're not gonna need that
coffee and then along the way it's going
to help your sleep too yeah the next
thing I want to talk about is uh
metabolism and what is the relationship
between testosterone and metabolism is
it as simple as higher testosterone
faster metabolism
yeah generally now how they interplay
exactly one with another
it's kind of complicated but
and to the point where I don't even
understand a small brain over here too
but the things that affect metabolism
that are going to decrease your
metabolism are the same things that are
going to decrease your testosterone in
general the the cortisol the insulin
resistance so by by working on those
things essentially your your
testosterone your metabolism are going
to boost together now if someone gets on
trt
you know they're going to notice a big
Improvement in their energy which is
metabolism right that to Define
metabolism simply it's your body's
ability to produce energy and so when
yeah when you take trt you start raising
your testosterone your energy levels are
going to increase because your body is
going to be functioning more efficiently
you laid out eight foods that people
should eat every single day to increase
their testosterone or a metabolism and
when I read through these eight foods to
increase your metabolism some of them I
was like okay got it right expected some
of them I was not good so let's just
start with uh the first two steak and
eggs I think obviously the food pyramid
would tell you don't do that yeah yeah
how do you kind of think about steak and
eggs for metabolism
so everything every not every but most
dietary recommendations I'm making are
in the con text of I want your insulin
to go down so that's particularly for
steak and eggs I want you eating more
protein less carbohydrates because
protein will minimally spike your
insulin a little bit but it's going to
be a very short spike and it's going to
come back down carbohydrates are going
to push your insulin way up and stay up
there so that's part of why I would say
steak and eggs but also steak
and eggs both are very high nutrition
like not just the protein and the
healthy fats they have they're full of
vitamins like I've started calling eggs
just like little multivitamins in you
know in food form like people think of
them as protein and cholesterol but
they've got vitamin A and selenium and
all these other things in them so stay
onions eggs or eggs are like my favorite
food too so I eat I try to eat three to
four a day minimum
um and or in a lot of times like five or
six with a steak you know and just keep
my body low insulin with those meals and
we get kind of into the weird parts of
like are these just normal eggs are they
like organic cage-free eggs are they
like egg whites what no not egg whites
never I mean I'll eat egg white but the
yolk is where most of the nutrition is
right the white is the protein so we
need both
how much from a nutrition standpoint
doesn't matter you know cage-free versus
you know not I don't think nutritionally
it makes a big difference now as far as
talking chemicals and that kind of stuff
that can be in the eggs yeah your
organic free range are probably gonna be
a lot better and you know where I live a
lot of people have chickens and I I have
people come to my clinic and pay me in
eggs and I love it you know are you
serious oh yeah it's absolutely like you
know they'll all pay um you know I you
know pay oops I pay them you know four
dollars per dozen that they bring me so
they want to pay off their whole visit
and eggs great bring me eggs yep yeah I
do it all the time and then you go ahead
and just make the eggs and you're good
to go oh yeah I love that yeah I need to
move on barter system yeah oh yeah uh
apple cider vinegar yeah I don't even
know what that is
but you're talking about uh taking some
of this or drinking some of it before
you eat a meal to help with digest it
explain what's happening here so that's
gonna do two things it's gonna it is
gonna increase your acid production a
bit which is great you know a lot of
people anymore are on these antacids you
know they're yeah they get heartburn all
the time for for a lot of those people
it's actually they don't have enough
stomach acid in their system and it
sounds counterintuitive but it's just
because they're they don't have enough
acid to actually close all the valves
and stuff so they get acid up into the
throat what apple cider vinegar is going
to do is get you get that acetic acid
that's that's the chemical in there that
does the magic so kind of any type of
vinegar will do apple cider vinegar is
just known for it and it's been studied
it's also going to decrease your insulin
response they did a study where they
took I think like 50 or 60 diabetics
and half of them
just did their normal thing
they were the control group the other
half they added in I think it was two
tablespoons of apple cider vinegar
before each meal
the group that did the apple cider
vinegar over the course of the study
lost like five to six pounds on average
the group that didn't lost nothing
they didn't change anything else it just
literally literally they had them take
the apple cider vinegar and it's because
of
the acetic acid has some interplay and
it's this isn't fully understood but it
has an interplay with our blood sugar to
keep that insulin level from spiking and
so you're becoming less insulin
resistant literally by taking apple
cider vinegar and one to two tablespoons
right before you eat now some people
they struggle with that because you know
it's it's vinegar right so it's pretty
acidic so I'm putting put that in some
water shoot it right before your meal
it's you're gonna notice an effect and
do that every meal
yeah ideally ideally if you can yeah
um it's just fascinating avocados
yeah avocados
um avocados help metabolism because
they're healthy fats
um the the uh the monounsaturated fats
in there we need those to make hormones
if you're not making hormones your
metabolism is going to tank every
hormone is made from fat every hormone
is made from fat and so when someone's
saying low fat low fat low fat no let's
eat more fat let's more healthy fat
right and avocados are just a great
source of that that kind of stuff to
give your body what it needs to make
um you know our hormones and the other
things it needs to do and then what
about chili peppers and oily fish these
two fish I was like okay we're starting
to get into areas where yeah I would
expect but Chili Peppers was not
something I expected yeah Chili Peppers
is an interesting one they've just shown
that
eating this or the the active ingredient
in those are the spicy ingredient is
capsaicin right and so
what the mechanism entirely is again
they don't really understand but they
have shown that
Chili Peppers can boost your metabolism
and I may have said in the post but I
think it was something like
10 maybe um and it's a it's a short-term
effect but
putting some spicier food does seem to
have an effect on metabolism and Chili
Peppers obviously uh being a food but
what about things like hot sauce on the
eggs like that I've heard people be like
oh that you know speeds up metabolism or
whatever is there any science that seems
to back that up I mean it may just go to
the same with chili peppers I I don't
know the last time I ate eggs without
hot sauce on them no I'm the type I've
got 20 hot sauces in my fridge you know
I I'm kind of a hot sized nerd but yeah
I definitely isn't gonna hurt you know
as long as it's a hot sauce that's not
full of sugar and you know that was all
those caveats but yeah it could be
because of the Chili Peppers yeah it's
just fascinating uh one of the things as
I've learned more and more about uh kind
of Science and biology and a lot of like
the diet and workout stuff and
everything is uh the military actually
has a lot of this stuff like kind of
built in uh it you'd be very hard to
walk into any chow hall uh on any
military base and not see people eating
eggs like pouring hot sauce on them and
I used to always think because there
wasn't a lot of condiments right maybe
there's some more signs yeah there you
go
um and then the last one is ginger which
uh I've never really heard anything talk
about what's going on with ginger
Ginger's doing doing a couple things um
Ginger is an antioxidant
um it's also going to help you know
Ginger is very soothing to the gut so if
there's some gut issues it's going to
help with that and then I think Ginger
kind of works on that a little bit of
the same principles as Chili Peppers
it's a very warming
um now root it's got kind of those same
bioactive chemicals that are just going
to speed things up a bit and just get
things going
and we've talked a lot about like
raising testosterone uh increasing
metabolism uh naturally when people
start to hear this stuff I think there's
been this explosion of interest and like
well why don't I just artificially
supplement my testosterone
um and from my understanding there's
pillows you can take there's things like
trt
um there's you know all sorts of uh uh
human growth hormone whatever how do you
just like if you were just starting out
trying to understand what even the
options were like what does that
spectrum look like yeah so most
most testosterone boosters that you hear
about on the radio or you see on a late
night commercial those are garbage man
most of those aren't going to be doing
much
um so as far as like actually replacing
now some of the supplements that we've
talked about with the tangar Ali and
ashwagandha and even for Dojo agresta
some of those those actually do have
have some benefit but if someone's
looking down the testosterone route I
mean the the only one that's really
going to get those big improvements as
far as if we're talking the
pharmaceutical side of things is going
to be the trt now I always encourage
people to go down the natural route
first let's work on your nutrition let's
work on your exercise and try to boost
it these you know more natural ways but
for some people the effects of that low
T are so great and affecting them so
much or if they're old enough if they're
in their 50s or 60s then yeah maybe
you'll have a conversation with with a
testosterone specialist now if you're if
you're going down there right you want
to talk to someone that has been doing
it for a while then knows what they're
doing because it's more complicated than
just hey give yourself a shot you know
once a week like you really need someone
that knows what they're doing and as
somebody kind of goes down that path
once they start are they pretty much
signing up to be doing this for the rest
of their life pretty much once you start
injecting
you know synthetic or you know an
outside source of testosterone if you're
if you go down that route yeah you're
signing up for a lifetime treatment what
is the uh side effect if you start and
then you come off of it is your body
just like shutting down testosterone
production and so it's hard to restart
it yeah it probably depends on how long
you've been on it now if someone's been
on trt for a month or two and they jump
off they're probably going to be okay
again talk with your doctor but
that is the issue so when you're
injecting that testosterone and they
inject a high amount average male will
produce 7 to 15 milligrams a day a lot
of the ways they do the the trt is
they'll inject like 200 milligrams at a
time and they're doing it like once
every other week or once a week type of
thing so physiologically that's just a
massive boost of testosterone in the
system and so that goes up to the
hypothalamus which is what kind of
starts all this up in the brain and the
hypothalamus says I'm good we don't need
to produce any more testosterone and so
you start to get that feedback loop of
I just don't need to produce it and
you're literally your hypothalamus will
shut down that pathway
what about human growth hormone igf-1
like there's all these things that um
you know when you play sports you hear
professional athletes all trying to do
all kinds of crazy stuff whatever
um what are those and how are they
related to some of the testosterone
stuff yeah so human growth hormone um
it's kind of produced in the kind of the
same pathway as as testosterone it gets
to the point where there's a chemical
called
t-h-e-a that gets converted to another
one and then they can go to human growth
hormone testosterone or estrogen
um the reason a lot of these athletes
are taking it or you know doping with it
is their recovery is much faster it's
not so much there probably is some
performance boost as well but it's the
recovery that these guys are really
looking for you know as far as like the
effects on um testosterone I haven't
really looked into you know what
supplement or what taking that can do
but
yeah it's definitely not something that
most people need
um if you're going down that route it's
usually you got something really majorly
wrong medically and so your doctor's
prescribing it for those reasons if
you're supplementing it outside
you're I think you're running the same
type of issues where your body's gonna
start shutting that down as we get older
we shouldn't make much HGH anyway
um most of our ACH is is made during
puberty and when we're really growing
and so doing that synthetically yeah the
brain's just gonna start shutting things
down that I don't think we want
um trt I don't think is necessarily
directly connected but uh there's a lot
of guys who um maybe they never talk
about it but like they're bodybuilders
or whatever and they take a lot of
steroids and you just kind of look at
something like all right that's probably
not physically possible without you know
some supplementation
um and we've seen is a number of these
guys have died in their late 40s early
50s you know just just earlier than you
would normally expect and definitely
than the average life expectancy what is
the understood kind of impact of any of
these synthetic things on like longevity
yeah I I'm not sure how much we really
know a lot of these things are newer
right but trt actually if it's done
right can improve longevity interesting
because they're getting themselves as
long as it's done right and do you want
to know guys have a doctor they're
getting their levels to a better
physiologic space so their body's
working better their metabolism is
working better all those things
um bone mass increased muscle muscle
mass actually and like muscle strength
is can be a predictor of longevity now
these bodybuilders and they are so
metabolically unhealthy most of them
that I wonder I don't know how much is
the steroids versus how much is the fact
that you're at a two percent body weight
human body is not made to be at a two
percent body weight right and so the
things they are doing to look like they
do
um I think play a massive role as well
they're just wrecking their their
hormones by doing all that a lot of
those guys they get to the point where
they can't produce like any of their
hormones anymore because they've been so
low fat and low calorie and all that
that they do for so long that it just
completely wrecks them yeah it um it is
this kind of crazy thing of like the
extremes may not be the the best thing
what is your like daily
um diet right you mentioned steak and
eggs and some of this stuff
um are you like just you know Sean Baker
literally that's it yeah yeah uh I I
love talking to him because he was just
like no literally like salt on the stick
yeah I drink water and that's it what
can be more simple right yeah I mean
like literally I was like I'm envious of
that yeah yeah um but but what is kind
of your daily look like and especially
because uh you're what I would consider
like more like a normal citizen where
you have four young kids you're uh have
your practice right like you you've got
all this stuff going on so it's not like
you can just say hey I'm gonna eat one
meal a day and it's this one thing right
um you also have to almost like deal
with feeding your kids right and all
that like what does that look like yeah
one part of it for me too is I love to
cook cookies one of my Main Hobbies um
most days I'm skipping breakfast um I
tend to I tend to fast you know people
call like an 18-6 fast I don't really
focus on it but I I wake up and I feel
good I don't feel I need the um for
lunch on I'm eating something high
protein um I tried to get 50 grams of
protein at lunch 70 if I can
um and and that's coming from chicken
beef pork whatever I'm not too picky on
that and I don't tend to eat any carbs
with lunch if I am going to have some
some carbs that's gonna be with dinner
and even lately a lot of times I just
feel better when I don't eat a lot of
carbohydrates the way I'm built I I am
very prone to insulin resistance my
whole family we we struggle with it and
so I try to keep my carbs really low I
I'm not always in ketosis you know the
ketogenic side but maybe I'll have a
little bit of rice with dinner but most
of the time I'm just eating the protein
I I don't go as far as Dr Baker does
with only eating steak and eggs like
that's that's what and right now it's
carnivore months I've seen Dr Baker's
post like he's like oh I ate this whole
prime rib for day 15 you know but uh
yeah I
any on a weekend I'll I'll have a piece
of pizza I'll have some but I I try to
keep that stuff to minimum most days I'm
eating high protein moderate fat and
pretty low carb what do you do with your
kids because you know I got a young
daughter and uh she's just now
transitioning from all you know breast
milk and milk and all that to now like
starting to eat solid foods and uh
there's this like weird thing where uh
you want her to eat right you want her
to learn like you know she's unifork now
and like like okay here we go but also
you're like hey I don't want to just
give her a bunch of like high sugar
foods right that seem to be kind of the
standards like how do you do you think
about that and especially because you
have some kids that are a little bit
older you know as kids and then you've
got some that are still very young yeah
so so my kids are probably a little
different that they grew up with me you
know as their dad so we started from a
young age I mean the first food that my
kids are giving is egg yolk you know
when we're starting transitioning more
real food I give them egg yolk and maybe
mash it up with some sweet potatoes
something like that so I start them
right away but my boy my oldest he's
seven he's he's getting to be more like
that where we'll be eating you know I'll
make some Curry or something and so
that'd be some rice and he'll just say
can I just have the chicken
and I just say sure yeah go for it like
I don't I don't care but yeah I we try
to just for my kids we don't have a lot
of junk in the house there's usually a
bag of cereal or a box of cereal
um but my kids don't eat it every day my
kids will do they do pancakes quite
often and we're trying to make those
higher protein pancakes where ideally
there's maybe a whole egg per pancake
type of thing and so so we try to
mitigate that and kids can get away with
you know eating more more carbs and
stuff but yeah the big thing is just
avoiding the junk with my kids they we
don't have candy in the house we have
ice cream only for a special thing you
know if it's my only my wife's birthday
was a couple days ago we had some some
ice cream but it's just finding that
balance right I don't want to be the the
one who's like you know my kids never
touch sugar ever because I think there's
a place to have a treat every once in a
while but
um yeah for the most part my kids know
the rule at my house is not you have to
eat your vegetables they're all my house
you gotta eat your me once you eat your
meat you can be done if you want to be
done you eat enough meat great and I I
portion there I give them about what I
think they need and a lot of times I'll
ask for more if they don't great they
they still got enough like yeah I mean
I'm not like I'm not as far as some guys
on the anti-vegetable route but I I
don't eat vegetables very often I don't
make them very often mostly because I
don't like them but I don't think it's
bad to eat them but in our house we
don't eat a lot what is the like
anti-vegetable argument
a lot of it on on those guys would be
some of the chemicals in the vegetables
the the oxalates the the phytic acid
um the
you know just just the chemicals that
the the plants have for protection
lectins gluten some of that stuff right
um and there there is some there are can
be some people who are real sensitive to
oxalates for instance oxalates you're
gonna find in like spinach and kale and
where your leafy greens but but if
someone wants to eat those that's easily
mitigated steam Your Spinach the
oxalates are going to break down so
that's the biggest argument that people
have
um I do tend to think that fruit is is
less harmful in general again I'm not
saying vegetables are harmful but fruit
isn't going to have as much of those
chemicals but you add in the fact that
our fruit has been so manipulated to be
so high sugar now you have a little bit
of issue there but if someone's eating
fruit vegetables and meat I think
they're they're going to be pretty damn
healthy one of my biggest conclusions in
talking to a bunch of people with all
kinds of the different perspectives is
like the zero to one Improvement is like
get off processed food right and get
more like natural food yeah and then
there's tons of variations between meat
and vegetarian fruitarian whatever
um but uh but but really getting out of
the processed food uh being the main you
know components of a diet is uh probably
the single most important thing that's
the single best thing that people can do
just get the junk out I would say get
the junk out increase your protein is
where you're gonna find the best bang
for your buck you'll probably get 80 90
of the Improvement you could get just by
making those two changes the last thing
I want to talk about is where do you get
your information from one of the things
that uh somebody like me who's more of
kind of a Layman trying to learn about
the stuff interested in this stuff uh
not just for myself my wife my kid right
uh my other family members is
you go on Twitter and it's hard to tell
who's real who's not right
um You Go even online and you know I was
talking to somebody yesterday uh who
swears by a specific diet and the
American Cancer Society literally labels
that uh kind of perspective of the world
as quackery
I was like okay I'm a chiropractor I'm
used to that term I've heard that one
before right so like as you're kind of
like looking through all this stuff uh
how do you maybe like what are the
sources of information that you turn to
and then like when you come across a
news source or they're like a framework
or somewhere that you use to evaluate
just to again increase the probability
like what you're reading is actually
valuable versus not yeah most one rule
of thumb is if it's in you know New York
Times or Washington Post or any of those
I I think it's probably BS you know like
because a lot of times they're cherry
picking these studies that they're
quoting now I might see a headline and
then I'll go read the study you know I
and I have studied enough that I know
how to interpret a study right so the
things I'm looking for when I'm reading
those studies is who funded this number
one a lot of times these Pro
you know anti-meat Pro vegetable study
for instance like they're going to be
funded a lot of times by organizations
that are you know the broccoli
Association exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah
these organizations that are anti-meat
in general right and that doesn't mean
that your study's bad but it introduces
some bias you know things like that so
that's one thing
it's hard like say you go on Twitter and
how many nutrition Bros are on Twitter
you know that read a nutrition book once
and now they're an expert and not say
they're given bad advice but you just
gotta
give it the what I call the sniff test
right if it smells if it smells funny it
probably is it's probably bad throw it
out I I study guide Benjamin bickman is
one anything that guy puts out now he's
more on the insulin resistance um he's a
great source if you want to learn how to
be healthy study Dr bickman's work he's
a professor at BYU and guys like Sean
Baker I just you know I love Dr Baker I
read his book too
I just read a lot and I try to find the
trend the trend right now the more we're
learning is higher protein is probably
the key
it used to for the last handful years
it's been
ketones you know keto keto keto keto
everything and I think keto is great too
but
you just gotta pull what resonates with
you out of what you're reading because
there's going to be something good and
almost anything puts out but like say
it's it's really hard to know the
biggest thing is who's saying it you
know when I have a
you know you get the extreme with Dr
Baker who's straight up carnivore dude
has only eaten meat for like seven years
and then you get some of these people on
the complete opposite side or they're
straight vegan
one thing I appreciate about Dr Baker is
he's not telling everyone you got to eat
like I do yeah I I did right he made
that very clear he was like look this
works for me some people they don't like
it they don't want to do it whatever
he's like that's fine but like this
works for me that that's what I
appreciate about Dr Baker is he found
what works for him and he recommends It
generally and he's seen it helped a lot
of his patients but he allows that
Nuance of if you feel better eating some
vegetables and fruit great do it whereas
you get the the extreme opposite side
the vegan side a lot of and there are
vegans that are the same way right there
are vegans that'll say yeah I feel
better eating this way and if that's the
case great good for you I I tend to
disagree I think it's an unhealthy way
to eat but you get the others that and
there's that moral ethical conversation
when we talk talk with a lot of in the
vegan Community but a lot of them you
know the meat is murder never eat meat
it's killing you killing you like now
see you're coming from a bias as well
because they you know they don't want to
harm animals and I can appreciate that
but
the source is going to be your biggest
key of yeah it's interesting that when
you actually look at the studies you go
and you see who funded is one of the
biggest things you look at yeah have you
ever seen a study funded by someone and
it went against what they believe
yeah it happens I mean a lot of times if
it's a true science organization then
yeah they just they just but this gets
into the realm of what gets published
and what doesn't a lot of times this
happens all the time where they will do
a study they won't like the result
they don't publish a study so you never
even see that study you never even see
some of these negative studies like
of the of the things that get published
it's like over 90 of them are positive
you can't tell me over 90 percent of
studies are positive they're just not
and and so there is that bias there as
well so you have to take some of that
with a grain of salt when you study but
yeah most of the time just looking
looking where some biases might be and
even like you know if you're reading an
article in a newspaper some
pay attention what you know is this
author someone who's written a lot about
you know anti-meet or Pro this Pro that
like you'll find the biases and then
they're gonna be cherry picking so the
biggest advice I could give someone is
just read a lot is study a lot read a
lot of books read a lot of Articles and
you'll start to find a trend
um that works for you you have one or
two books that uh you suggest that
people are interested in health
testosterone metabolism like are there
one or two that stick out to you the
biggest one that I recommend to everyone
is actually Dr bickman's book it's
called why we get sick
um Dr bickman has been studying insulin
resistance for 20 20 plus years I think
um like I say he's a professor down at
Brigham Young University in Utah and
that one is the key to
insulin resistance is tied to every
pretty much every chronic disease and is
the cause of a lot of them so if someone
reads that book they can better
understand what insulin resistance is
and how they can help it Dr bickman goes
into that as well I do tell people to
read the carnivore diet which is Dr
Baker's book um I think it's a great one
the other one as far as like Health goes
I tell people to read is why why we
sleep which is by Matthew Walker who's a
neuroscientist I think Cal Berkeley or
Stanford he's out there in California
but that's just a great one of
learning the how important sleep is for
your health uh that all three of those
are are great books I haven't read uh
why we get sick so I'm gonna pick that
one up and yeah and now you give me a
reading a assignment which I always
appreciate yeah um where can we send
people to find you on the internet if
they want to learn more uh either about
the Chiropractic practice or some of
this other stuff yeah so my chiropractic
practice is in Wyoming if anyone's ever
driving through Star Valley Wyoming on
their way to Jackson stop in Star Valley
it's it's great but online is you know
on Twitter is the easiest way to get me
it's just Dr Rich Huntsman um on Twitter
and then I do have a website that's Dr
huntsman.com and I've got a couple
things on there some Guides of things to
avoid if people want to learn more about
the Plastics and that stuff things to
avoid to help their testosterone there's
a free guide on there that they can
download
um and I also you know I help people I
help people at this house though like I
do virtual coaching and that kind of
stuff so people want to reach out to me
on Twitter that's that's the best way to
get me I feel like I got a master class
today so I really appreciate you coming
and talking to me and answering all my
dumb questions but you doing some
amazing work and I think that just more
people who get educated right I I always
look at this as like the first step is
kind of educating themselves on uh what
are the potential downfalls of things
that they're doing in their daily life
some people will change some people
won't right and that's okay but if
you've got the information at least you
got you know the opportunity to change
and it really just comes down to kind of
like do you want to or not right uh no
one's gonna hold a gun to your head and
say filter your water right right uh at
least not yet in America
um and so uh we'll we'll see how it goes
but I really appreciate the time and I
hope that everyone goes and checks out
uh you both on Twitter and at the
website we'll do it again in the future
yeah appreciate you having me